hi i'm riya and this is my recipe for
chocolate tart
one of my favorite dessert is the tart
they can seem really intimidating but i
wanted to show you how easy it was to
make
make sure butter and egg is room
temperature because if you use room
temperature butter with cold eggs they
don't mix well together when you mix
butter and egg you can use hand mixer or
whisk but once you add flour you should
switch to spatula because you don't want
to create a lot of gluten because the
cookie dough will become tough and hard
if you over mix some baking recipes say
to leave the butter at room temperature
but they don't mention that eggs should
also be room temperature which is very
important in recipes like this one
you also want to rest the dough for 30
minutes so it relaxes the gluten and
also the dough is really soft so you
want to make the butter a little harder
and it's easier to roll it out if the
dough breaks when you're molding it it's
okay you can patch it with leftover
dough make sure to poke holes so that
the dough doesn't poof up if you make
something difficult to make and you make
it really well it can boost your
confidence so this tour is great for any
beginner cooks who wants to challenge
themselves a little bit also i use the
instant coffee in this recipe because it
kind of gives a nice bitterness and a
flavor that balances out with the
sweetness of the chocolate so that the
tart doesn't become overly sweet but if
you don't like coffee you can totally
skip this step and it will work just
fine it's just a flavor preference when
you're pouring wet ingredients into the
chocolate pour everything at once then
count 30 seconds and then start mixing
it makes really nice shiny chocolate
filling
also make sure to use good quality dark
chocolate because this recipe is very
simple so quality is very important so
when you bake it make sure to take the
tar out
when the center part is slightly
jiggling because if you overcook it the
chocolate filling start cracking shake a
little bit and if the center slightly
jiggled that is when you have to take
out from the oven this recipe i learned
from a pastry chef i used to work with
at the restaurant in l.a so it's totally
restaurant quality dessert and you can
impress anyone who loves chocolate this
chocolate tar is silky and rich so you
will be satisfied just like
tiny slice this recipe seems a little
bit challenging but if you follow step
by step you can totally make it and you
will be impressed by yourself impress
yourself first and impress other people
next
and it's totally worth that
thank you
i cannot be alex
so a few years ago there was a trend
where you roll up apple slices onto a
pie sheet and made a little tart so i
was wondering if there was anything i
could make that would look pretty like
that and i came up with this idea using
crepes instead of paishi i wasn't sure
if it's gonna work first but i tried it
anyways and when i think of crepes my
favorite feeling is strawberry and
whipped cream so instead of apples i
decided to use strawberries
the important thing about making crepes
is rest the dough for at least 30
minutes because we are mixing with milk
and flour which creates gluten and you
don't want to make chewy and rubbery
crepes
if you want you can also rest it
overnight and make it the next day i
chose cream cheese filling because it's
a little thicker so easy to work with
you are ending up making a bunch of
crepes for this recipe and that will
take time but i also think it's fun as
well so i tested this and made a pretty
small version that was really really
cute
but when i make dessert i usually want
to share so i don't want to make it just
for myself
when you're making a home it's a little
bit messy because you're spreading cream
onto the crepe and rolling it up but
it's worth the effort and it was a mess
because it's really pretty and i'm sure
whoever you're going to give it to will
be super impressed
make sure to cut the strawberries very
thin it's similar to a crepe cake
because it's layered but just a
different presentation because the
crepes are vertical instead of
horizontal
so instead of stopping making small
little tart i was just kept rolling and
rolling and rolling and i ended up
making a large crepe cake i think
rolling it up it's the most fun and
difficult part because it's kind of like
building a snowman it's the same cake
all the way through it just gets bigger
also after you make this rolled crepe
big enough then you can start layering
it on the side instead of rolling them
what you end up with is a super pretty
rolled of crepes all standing up with
strawberries kind of looking like a
flower which is why i called this a rose
crepe cake this is a perfect dessert to
bring on afternoon tea party or just to
make with your friends sometime
[Music]
i was filming this recipe late at night
because i wasn't sure if it's gonna work
so i was kind of testing and shooting at
the same time and alex and scott was
also shooting leia night so we shared
together and both of them are super
impressed so this recipe is something
i'm really proud of because i've never
seen this type of cake before
so i would like you to make it and i
also want you to be proud of it
[Music]
so this recipe was kind of assigned to
me by alden so he made a multi-flavor
sheep pan pie video and we as a team
wanted to see what else can we make
multi-flavor i wanted to make something
easy like i didn't want to make each
flavor from scratch so i wanted to make
one cookie dough and add in different
flavors
[Music]
using brown sugar is very important in
order to give the cookie that chewy
texture that i like
and also using a little white sugar
helps giving a crispy texture
it's good to combine both it's important
to use two type of sugar to make this
american style cookie i feel like
chocolate chip cookie is very unique to
america i feel like this chocolate chip
cookie it's a little bit rustic shape
each individual cup gives a different
shape and kind of i don't know like i
feel like it's imperfect but this
imperfection make it perfect
we kind of came up with simple flavor
combinations that everyone likes like
chocolate chip cookie and peanut butter
and white chocolate macadamia nuts which
is something that's underrated i think
[Music]
i think it's the best multi-flavor
skillet cookie recipe out there i don't
know how many out there
[Music]
i used parchment paper to bake so i can
take it out and transport it to a plate
but if you just want to serve in a
skillet you can do so you don't need to
use the parchment paper each cookie is
next to each other based on how well
their flavor profile combined and of
course everyone wants to eat the middle
part because you can eat whole flavor so
each of six different flavors all in one
cookie
[Music]
and also i cut it in a pea seed so you
can enjoy different flavor combinations
like chocolate chip cookie with peanut
butter cookie and a white chocolate
macadamia cookie with double chocolate
cookies
[Music]
and i think this cookie does a good job
of capturing a lot of different
characters it's difficult to make
imperfect perfect cookie like if you
have american chocolate chip cookie it
kind of has a crack and chocolate chip
is sometimes not evenly distributed
it may have a dent somewhere but it's
cute in a way a whole imperfection makes
a great cookie perfect
it's not something you can intend it to
make it that way but it happens that way
but it's perfect in the way not sure if
you get it i
feel like i'm talking about cookie
philosophy
i don't know i think you just try make
it and maybe you understand what i'm
talking about
[Music]
so i was looking on the internet and
found this really cool cookie called the
shakashaka cookies shakashaka is
onomatopoeia for shaking noise in
japanese so when you shake something and
make noise that is shakashaka the person
made two cookies glued together and put
sprinkles inside so when you shake it
you can see the sprinkles inside moving
and it was very cute the recipe doll
looks very complicated they used a
special kind of sugar called palatinos
which is not sold in regular grocery
stores so i wanted to make it but make
it very simple so everyone can make a
home that's something i always wanted to
include in my video that something
everyone can make a home that's the
great thing about tasty i think and
making this cookie was very fun i made
this video for tasty junior initially
and i had the opportunity to work with
kids
it was very fun to cook with little
girls especially as a child actor i
walked to it she was so impressed
she told me i could be a chef in the
future and i should open the restaurant
and it was very cute and sweet
i was thinking maybe i could use
strawberry candy and melt it there is
also another cookie called the stained
glass cookie which is very popular
so i used the jolly launcher instead of
the special sugar and took two cookies
together with white chocolate so it
tastes better
when i was reading comment i saw some
audience said jolly launcher is too hard
so if you buy into it you might break
your teeth
but when you bake a jolly launcher
spread very thinly so don't worry about
breaking a teeth
you won't break your teeth i'm looking
for you
this video became viral and i saw a lot
of people make it
i also saw some people made it for a
bake sale and it's a great feeling when
someone actually make it and have fun
with it
i think also shakashaka cookies is a
cute name for japanese cookie but if you
translate it it's become shake shape
cookie which is not so catchy
it was our general manager ashley who
was sitting next to me and said oh that
looks like an aquarium so that's why i
named it so don't be afraid of breaking
your teeth
it's actually tasty kids love that and
you can customize it you can put love
letter in it and make it fancy make it
fancy
make it fancy
[Music]
[Applause]
you